la información de salud es con más
Romero salas en directo América Buen día
para usted Mar buenos días Ángela
volvemos al brote de la viruela del mono
todavía considerado una emergencia de
salud pública internacional Sí vamos a
irla recordando no dejarla caer del foco
de atención pública recordemos que se
declaró así en 2022 en julio de 2022 y
el jueves pasado se reunió el comité
asesor de emergencias de la MS para
reevaluarlo todavía no sabemos qué
conclusión Ana han sacado los casos por
suerte una buena noticia se han
ralentizado en todo el mundo Gracias a
las campañas de vacunación gracias al
acceso de tratamientos también a medidas
de control y de protección social algo
que como decíamos no Bueno pues nos
habla de que han funcionado todas estas
estrategias que se implementaron en su
momento pero que también como decíamos
puede estar augurando el fin al final de
este interés público alrededor de este
brote que sabemos que podría conllevar
también pues el fin de investigaciones
además recursos destinados a esta
enfermedad que recordemos es endémica
todavía en varios países del continente
africano siempre puede volverse a
convertir en un brote internacional ya
hemos visto que puede pasar podría
volver a suceder en el futuro pero
repasemos las cifras de la Organización
Mundial de la Salud para saber bien de
qué estamos hablando aquí en azul las
regiones principales es la región
americana del continente de las Américas
en rojo es la región europea vemos Esa
primera ola europea que se suma luego a
la ola americana y vemos igual como lo
más destacable es que hubo semanas
recordemos alrededor de agosto de 2022
donde se sumaron más de 6.000 casos
semanales ahora Estamos en unas pocas
decenas en la última semana en todo el
mundo fueron 159 casos los que se
registraron de viruela del mono ahí lo
tiene Y cuál es la situación del
continente americano pues es todavía la
región donde más casos se detectan
aunque no sea nada en comparación Bueno
nada es una mala palabra no pero sea
mucho menor en comparación con meses
anteriores la Organización Mundial de la
Salud todavía considera que el riesgo en
las regiones alto los países con más
casos detectados desde el inicio del
brote son Estados Unidos Brasil Colombia
Aunque es importante destacar Perú que
por ejemplo es el que más casos tiene
cuando se compara con la población que
tiene en Estados Unidos Brasil se
detectaron 42 y 28 casos la última
semana respectivamente y no ha habido
cambios respecto a la semana anterior en
Estados Unidos en cambio Si ha habido
una mejora en Brasil aquí ven es la
última columna que se ve el resto de los
países por ejemplo no llegan ni a diez
casos nuevos detectados quizás el más
sorprendente es chile que hay un aumento
muy significativo de casos pero vemos
que pasa de dos a nueve es decir todavía
en cifras bajas podría ser algo puntual
que no tenga que ser particularmente
alarmante usted Nos estaba diciendo el
inicio de su intervención que la
vacunación ha sido muy importante para
frenar el brote tenemos datos de la
efectividad pues hasta ahora no los
teníamos pero hace poco se publicó un
informe ahora vamos a ver las cifras
pero recordemos primero que se usaba una
vacuna contra la viruela una enfermedad
digamos hermana de la viruela del mono
pero no era la misma Entonces se usó
bajo estos preceptos de emergencia en el
que se intentó encontrar Qué recursos y
cómo se podrían aprovechar actualmente
pero se sabía que era segura No se sabía
tanto Qué tan efectiva podía ser contra
la viruela del mono además por problemas
de suministro se pasó a sustituir el
esquema original que era de dos dosis
por una dosis para que alcanzara para
más personas por suerte ya también con
unos meses de perspectiva Pues eso
permite revisar los datos que se han ido
acumulando Durante este tiempo de este
brote desde julio bueno empezó antes de
hecho en abril de 2022 Y tenemos estos
primeros resultados publicados Hace unos
días en la revista nature la principal
conclusión Es que la efectividad de la
vacuna en contra del contagio es del 86%
con un intervalo de confianza entre el
59 y el 95% en Incluso en el caso más
bajo estaría por encima del 50% que es
lo que se pide bajo Los estándares
Internacionales la muestra fue de dos
más de 2.000 personas y en el grupo
vacunado que era la mitad más o menos
hubo cinco contagios en el que no estaba
vacunado hubo 16 muy bien por la
tecnología pero pasa lo mismo de siempre
las vacunas no a todo el mundo si es una
historia que no suena desgraciadamente
familiar especialmente
no en este caso solo hay un
suministrador de vacunas que es la
farmacéutica bavarian nordic y hace que
eso que pocos suministros al final
terminen en las manos de las personas de
los países sobre todo que más pudieron
comprar que más acceso rápido tienen a
esto que más dinero tienen también por
supuesto estamos hablando de Estados
Unidos también de varios países europeos
en el continente americano por ejemplo
la Ops aseguró 100.000 dosis que
llegarán también desde pues desde
bavaria Norte y hubo algunos acuerdos
bilaterales que hizo que hubiera es
algunos casos algunos países que
tuvieron acceso a vacunar y que pudieron
empezar a inmunizar a su población pero
por ejemplo en el continente africano
solo se está vacunando a personas a raíz
de ensayos clínicos no se están
distribuyendo masivamente estas vacunas
y esto recordando que África es donde
tienen de nuevo países donde esta
enfermedad es endémica desde inicios de
2022 en el continente africano se
registraron
26 muertes que es mucho más que todas
las que se han registrado en el resto
del mundo en este brote internacional si
había algo de esperanza de que la
internalización de este brote llevar
Pues a más recursos o más atención para
frenarlo por ahora no podemos decir que
eso esté sucediendo ni siquiera voy a
pelear más por supuesto ya no gracias a
usted por la información gracias Ángela